Let's try to evaluate
the indefinite integral 1
over the square root of
1 minus x squared dx.
And you might try something
like u substitution,
but you'll find out
that it doesn't get you
very far with this integral.
And so instead, we
will do something
called trig substitution.
And the whole idea behind
trigonometric substitution
is to substitute for x
with a trig function,
so that this might simplify
using some trig identities.
And maybe it'll turn this
entire integral into something
that we can actually integrate.
And so the trig
substitution that we'll do--
and the big clue here is when
we see this 1 minus x squared.
And in fact, if we ever
see an a squared minus an x
squared-- so 1 is
1 squared, minus x
squared-- it's a
pretty good clue
that we would want to
substitute with something times
sine of theta.
In this case, if we just
make the substitution,
if we say that x is equal
to-- let me do it over here.
If we say that x is
equal to sine of theta,
then what we have under
the radical right over here
is going to become 1 minus sine
squared theta, which is cosine
squared theta.
And then we could take
the square root of that.
And that might simplify all
of this business a good bit.
And we just want to make sure
that we're not artificially
constraining our x more
than what the domain here
would otherwise constrain our x.
So if you look over here,
the x right over here
has to have an absolute
value less than 1.
Or another way of saying it,
the domain right over here, x
has to be greater than negative
1 and less than positive 1.
If it was 1, then
the denominator right
here is going to be 0.
If it was greater than 1
or less than negative 1,
then all of a
sudden, you're going
to have a negative
under the radical sign.
So already, our
domain is constrained
for these values of x.
So if we say x is sine
theta, this actually
allows x to be anywhere
between negative 1 and 1,
including negative 1 and 1.
So we're not constraining x
more than the domain has already
constrained it.
Since we're going to have to
unwind the substitution later
on, let's also
define theta in terms
of x and in a way
that's not consistent
with this top statement.
So let's also say that
theta is equal to arcsin,
or inverse sine, of x.
And what does this do?
Well, this actually constrains
what our theta is going to be.
If I draw a unit circle--
my best to draw one.
So this is my unit circle.
And if I come up with
a particular x that's
going to be essentially
the potential sine value,
arcsin is going to
give an angle that
is in the first or
fourth quadrant.
So if we say that this is
our x, then the arcsin of x
is going to be this
angle, not this one
out here in the second quadrant.
If we say that this is
our x, then our arcsin
is going to be this angle.
So this right over
here constrains
theta to be less than
or equal to pi/2,
so less than or equal to
that, and greater than
or equal to negative pi/2.
This is the way the arcsin
function is typically defined.
It will return a value between
negative pi/2 and pi/2.
Or another way of saying that,
in this range right over here
on the unit circle.
And this will be
important later on when
we try to simplify
this expression.
But let's actually try
to simplify it now.
Before we do that, we
could substitute x,
but we're also going to
have to substitute for dx.
So let's figure out
what dx is equal to.
dx is equal to--
well, the derivative
of sine theta with respect to
theta is cosine theta d theta.
So now we're ready to actually
evaluate, or at least simplify.
So our original integral becomes
the integral of 1 times dx.
Well, dx is cosine
theta d theta.
Cosine theta-- I'll put
the d theta out here--
over the square root
of 1 minus x squared,
which is now going to be 1
minus sine squared theta.
Well, what is 1 minus
sine squared theta?
Well, that's going to
be cosine squared theta.
Let me write this down.
1 minus sine squared theta is
equal to cosine squared theta.
This comes straight out of
the unit circle definition
of trig functions.
Cosine squared plus sine
squared is equal to 1.
So we can rewrite
this as being equal
to the indefinite integral
of cosine theta d theta
over the square root of
cosine squared theta.
Now, we have to be a
little bit careful here.
We have to think about
whether cosine theta is going
to be either
positive or negative
or maybe we don't know.
If we square a number and
then take its principal root,
we're essentially taking
the absolute value of it.
If cosine of theta
was, say, negative 1
and we square it and then
take the principal root,
it'll get 1.
If cosine theta was positive
1, then we still get 1.
So right now, all we
can do, without knowing
more information about
cosine of theta, is
say that this can be
rewritten as cosine theta
over the absolute
value of cosine theta.
If you square something and then
take the positive square root,
the principal
square root, you're
essentially just taking
its absolute value.
And so it's really tempting
to simplify this more,
but we can't quite do
it without understanding
what cosine of theta is
going to be equal to.
Well, lucky for us, we've
already constrained theta
to be equal to arcsin of x.
And so that says
that theta is going
to be between negative
pi/2 and pi/2.
And in this range
of thetas, we're
always in kind of
the positive x-axis.
So cosine of theta, which is
the x-coordinate for wherever
we sit on the unit circle, is
always going to be positive.
And since cosine of theta--
so let me make this clear.
Arcsin of theta
is equal to arcsin
of x tells us that
cosine of theta
is going to be greater
than or equal to 0.
It's going to be
non-negative, I guess
is the best way to say it,
not necessarily positive.
It could still be equal to 0.
So it's going to
be non-negative.
And since it's non-negative,
the absolute value
of a non-negative number
is just the number itself.
So this is just going to
be equal to the integral--
and I'll just do it in one
color-- of cosine theta
over cosine theta
d theta, which is
just equal to the integral of d
theta, which is equal to theta
plus C. And now all we have to
do is unwind this substitution.
We already know that theta
is equal to arcsin of x.
So we could say this is
equal to arcsin x plus C.
And we're done.
Using trig substitution,
we were able to evaluate
this indefinite integral.
And another way you could
think about it is we've
just figured out what the
derivative of arcsin of x is.
By taking the
antiderivative of this,
we got arcsin of x plus C. If
we take the derivative of arcsin
of x, we get this
business right over here.